en principio han apuntado un poco a
estrategias perfectamente diseñadas
mientras keiko fujimori tenía el
escenario principal para poder atacar al
candidato castillo y tratar de bajarle
la llanta con la finalidad que su esos
dos puntos que le están diferenciando
según las últimas encuestas difundidas
el día de hoy en perú se dan pues frenar
dicha dicha subida o dicho el liderazgo
que tiene castillo en las encuestas
mientras por el lado del castillo la
estrategia también previsible que tenía
sobre todo para luchar en esta en este
debate estaba apuntando principalmente a
aclarar aquellos fantasmas que le habían
atribuido durante el desarrollo de su
campaña por otro lado y lo que sí me
sorprende es evidentemente cierta
pobreza
en ambos candidatos por ejemplo para
hablar en cuanto a la estadística y en
cuanto al reflejo de los ataques por
ejemplo keiko fujimori anunció y
atribuyó en más de una oportunidad que
la izquierda y los gobiernos regionales
de ese espectro político tenían en la
mayor deficiencia cuando en realidad si
hacemos una contabilidad entre la
ejecución presupuestal del año 2019 y
2020 justo los gobiernos regionales y
gobiernos locales de keiko fujimori han
tenido menos nivel de ejecución
presupuestal que los de perú libre y el
candidato y perú libre tampoco se
defendió y habló acerca del tema
entonces si hay una pobreza en materia
estadística por otro lado en esta
dinámica
keiko fujimori se muestra un poco más
lucha por la experiencia que tiene en el
debate y que el candidato castillo
intenta dar la performance en relación a
ciertos manejos de aspectos
y coincido con zabaleta en el sentido de
que la explicación del cómo lo van a
hacer de cómo están recibiendo o cómo
van a recibir la salud económica del
país permitiría acaso todas estas
demandas de promesas que están
realizando ambos candidatos nadie hace
esas explicaciones y creo que los
votantes están esperando mucho más de
ambos candidatos